once upon a time there was a city in the
middle of hessen not too big and not too
small it conjured up a large castle on a
hill for its most famous sons not just
any old castle a palace they called grim
world and people came from far and wide
to see it world as a museum for young
and old alike
we have exhibits for children things to
touch try out and make themselves but it
also appeals to adults to tourists
scholars art lovers and of course Grimm
fans a large exhibition area is of
course devoted to the fairy tales of the
Brothers Grimm here you can meet a frog
King look for Sleeping Beauty behind
hedges or ask a magic mirror who's the
fairest in the land
I've only been here half an hour and I'm
enraptured it's full of surprises
I'm good waiter here Martha Cystic the
building is really fun to walk through
if you like to explore every corner
invites discovery it's certainly an
enrichment for castle
all in all very impressive I recommend
it the museum also displays treasures
for instance first editions of the Grimm
brothers children's and household tales
from 200 years ago they're copies that
belong to the brothers with their own
handwritten notes Jakob who was born in
1785 in Hana and his brother villain a
year later to attend grammar school the
brothers went to live with their aunt in
Castle
they lived in the central German city
off and on for about thirty years it was
here that they began to collect their
folktales urban world puts the brothers
in a historical perspective shows what
they achieved in their lifetimes the
works they left behind but it also
touches on what they mean today in our
time or than anything their work as
philologists remains influential the
brothers studied the development of
Germanic languages and began a mammoth
work the largest and most comprehensive
dictionary of the German language but in
the world of fairy tales that continues
to fascinate children to this day it's
incredible that the tales are just as
enchanting today as they were when they
were first put down on paper perhaps
even more so thanks to modern technology
you can share a table with the Seven
Dwarfs and they lived happily ever after
until their next visit to grimm world in
Casas